Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Domenica scorsa, mia figlia mi ha chiesto:
"Quando presenti il libro a Torino?".
Io ho detto: "Ma guarda,
non me lo ricordo.
Aspetta che guardo sul telefono,
c'è una mail con tutto il programma".
Ho aperto le mail,
stavo per mettermi a cercare,
e ne è ho visto subito una, dal titolo:
"Ricette da fare con la zucca,
per Thanksgiving".
Era del New York Times.
Io sono molto appassionato di zucca,
perché il piatto che mi viene meglio,
e non è particolarmente complesso,
è la crema di zucca
con le castagne dentro.
E quindi ho detto:
"Fantastico, qui adesso ne trovo un sacco,
e faccio una gran bella figura".
Per cui, ho incominciato
a scorrere quella mail.
A un certo punto, ne ho vista una
particolarmente innovativa,
ho cliccato e mi ha portato
sul sito del New York Times.
Anziché aprirsi, si è aperta la mascherina
che mi proponeva gli abbonamenti.
E diceva: "Abbonati a New York Times!"
Ma io sono già abbonato al New York Times,
perché non mi riconosce?
E allora dice: "Altrimenti,
inserisci le tue credenziali".
Ma io non ho la minima idea
di quali siano le mie credenziali:
e quindi, mi sono messo
a cercare le credenziali,
che da qualche parte,
sul telefono, ci dovevano essere.
Mentre cercavo tutte le password
dentro il telefono,
ho visto la password
di una compagnia telefonica,
e mi è venuto in mente
che quella compagnia telefonica
mi sta inseguendo da mesi
perché io restituisca un vecchio decoder.
Un decoder che era di due case fa:
non ho la minima idea dove sia.
Ho anche provato a dire loro
che io non so cosa farmene:
ve lo pago, ma io
non ce l'ho più quel decoder!
No, vogliono il decoder.
Allora mi ricordavo
che mi bombardavano con degli sms.
Allora ho detto: fammi vedere
a che punto siamo arrivati.
Sono andato a vedere negli sms,
e negli sms ho trovato un messaggio,
che mi ero dimenticato, dell'oculista
che diceva che dovevo portare
le mie figlie martedì alle 19.
Allora mi sono girato,
e ho detto a mia figlia:
"Martedì, martedì abbiamo l'oculista!".
E lei mi ha detto: "E come fai"?
- "Ti ho detto che andiamo dall'oculista"
- "E salti la presentazione? "
- "Ma cosa c'entra la presentazione?
Dobbiamo andare dall'oculista!"
Lei mi ha detto: "Ho capito:
ma tu stavi guardando il telefono
per dirmi quando c'era la presentazione".
E io ho detto: "Ah, è vero.",
Ho fatto un passo indietro,
e ho immaginato tutto quello che ho detto:
ero passato dall'oculista, il decoder,
la password, la crema di zucca.
E vero, io ho preso il telefono
per un'altra cosa.
E lì, mi sono reso conto
del naufragio della mia attenzione.
Quante volte voi prendete
il telefono in mano
perché dovete fare una cosa
che vi sembra importantissima,
cioè fare una telefonata?
Mi devo ricordare,
di telefonare a quella persona,
devo mandare una mail, scrivere una cosa,
comprare il biglietto di un treno.
Poi lo prendete, e vedete che avete
dieci notifiche di WhatsApp,
Dieci notifiche sembra: "Wow,
chi mi avrà scritto dieci cose?"
Vai dentro subito:
e trovi la chat, per esempio,
dei compagni di classe -
che è una ancora delle più innocue -
che propongono la pizzata,
e ti propongono la pizzata
tra tre giovedì.
E tu però già guardi,
quindi non sai più cosa devi fare
vai a vedere - eh no,
ma tu tra tre giovedì non puoi.
E allora inizi a dire:
"Cosa faccio, non vado io
o propongo un'altra data? "
E poi vedi un messaggio,
un news alert che ti è arrivato,
che dice che il seggio senatoriale
del Nevada l'hanno vinto i democratici.
E allora dico:
"Cavoli, ah, Trump l'ha presa
in quel posto: fantastico."
Allora io scrivo subito a un amico
che è proprio drogato
di politica americana,
e gli chiedo:
"Ma questo cosa significa davvero?
Cosa significa per Trump?"
E vado avanti così.
E poi, a un certo punto dico:
perché ho preso il telefono?
Cosa dovevo fare?
Allora io faccio così,
faccio il percorso all'indietro:
dov'era il telefono?
Lo appoggio nel posto dov'era,
mi sgombro la testa da Trump,
dai democratici, dal Nevada,
dalla pizza di classe, eccetera eccetera.
Cerco di tornare a uno stato
di natura originale, e dico:
"Che cosa dovevo fare di importante?".
Il problema che abbiamo oggi, secondo me,
è che noi abbiamo una grande
confusione del nostro tempo.
Noi abbiamo bisogno di riscoprire
una nuova ecologia,
una sostenibilità del nostro tempo.
Quando si da al telefono
a una ragazza, o a un ragazzo,
prima si dava quando andava
alle superiori;
poi dopo l'esame di terza media;
poi in prima media;
poi alla fine delle elementari.
Io adesso ormai ho le figlie
che hanno 15 anni,
non so se siamo andati indietro
e si da all'ultimo anno di asilo,
non oso chiederlo.
Però cosa succedeva?
I genitori avevano ognuno il suo metodo.
C'era il genitore molto progressista,
che faceva scrivere dal figlio
una sorta di documento,
in cui il figlio diceva:
"Mi impegno a non usare il telefono
in questo, questo, quel momento".
Quelli che si inventavano
genitori avvocati,
che facevano un contratto coi figli.
Poi c'erano i genitori
che invece dicevano:
"Se tu lo usi nel modo giusto,
avrai dei premi".
Quelli che, invece, dicevano:
"no, se tu lo usi nel modo sbagliato
ci sono le punizioni".
E poi c'era la scatola,
tipo una scatola all'ingresso:
quando si va a pranzo,
si deposita il telefono nella scatola.
E lì, mi è venuto in mente
Sergio Marchionne.
Sergio Marchionne è stato
un manager italiano, molto noto,
che oggi non c'è più.
Ha guidato la Fiat, l'ha messa insieme
con Chrysler e Jeep.
Ecco: Sergio Marchionne,
la sua scatoletta,
era un sacchetto di plastica, una busta
in cui lui teneva tre telefoni:
uno con una SIM americana,
una Svizzera e una italiana,
Uno per per il lavoro
in Italia, uno in America;
e uno perché i figli vivevano in Svizzera.
E aveva anche, sempre,
due bottigliette di thè con aromi strani
che comprava in America, thé freddo.
E lui teneva sempre
i telefoni nel sacchetto,
e li tirava fuori
solo se ne aveva bisogno.
Perché diceva che quando tu tieni
il telefono sul tavolo,
il telefono si frega la tua attenzione.
E poi, diceva - io dicevo: "Vbabè,
uno può anche fare due cose insieme".
E lui diceva: "No, il multitasking
significa che tu puoi fare:
due cose male; tre cose malissimo;
e quattro cose in modo schifoso.
Questa è una certezza:
fanne una sola alla volta".
E mi ha insegnato una cosa:
mi ha insegnato il valore del tempo vuoto.
Allora, Sergio Marchionne e il tempo vuoto
sembrano due concetti lontanissimi,
perché era uno che lavorava
18 ore al giorno:
si è veramente consumato, di lavoro.
Eppure, lui faceva così:
quando arrivò alla Fiat,
ogni due ore segnava, sulla sua agenda,
20 minuti, o mezz'ora,
dove scriveva "Pasquale".
All'inizio, la sua nuova assistente
ironizzava con le altre dell'ufficio,
e diceva: "Pasquale?
Ma chi sarà Pasquale?
Qualcosa che ci nasconde?
Un'amica , qualcuno che non vuole -
con cui parla, e non ce lo vuole dire?".
Invece, Pasquale era lui.
Pasquale era il suo tempo
necessario per capire le cose,
il tempo di cui aveva bisogno
per digerire le cose.
Dopo due ore di riunione,
sei pieno di stimoli, bombardamenti.
Hai bisogno di telefonare a qualcuno;
hai bisogno di spiegarti, di capire.
E quello era il tempo
di cui lui aveva bisogno.
Allora, noi abbiamo bisogno
di recuperare questo:
un'ecologia del nostro tempo.
E dobbiamo fare una cosa fondamentale:
noi dobbiamo distinguere le cose urgenti
dalle cose importanti.
Lo stiamo vedendo, anche,
sulla crisi climatica.
Noi, continuamente, le cose importanti
sappiamo benissimo quali sono;
ma invece, noi rincorriamo
le cose urgenti.
E allora, ci sono le cose attuali,
del momento, che ci dicono:
"Ma no, riapriamo le centrali a carbone;
ma no, non possiamo in questo momento,
la congiuntura, e ci sono le bollette;
quindi non possiamo preoccuparci
di ciò che è importante".
Invece ognuno di noi,
anche per il proprio tempo,
deve sapere quali sono le cose importanti.
Le cose importanti
sono facili da distinguere:
ognuno di noi sente dentro che cosa sono.
Le cose importanti
sono quelle che, se non le facciamo,
avremo un rimpianto.
Le cose importanti
sono quelle che servono a costruire senso,
che fanno la differenza nella nostra vita.
Le cose importanti
sono quelle che mettono un tassello
della costruzione di un progetto,
della costruzione di un sogno,
che provano a costruire
un pezzo di futuro.
Allora, noi siamo bombardati
da cose urgenti.
Tutti i giorni corriamo
come la ruota del criceto,
e siamo, abbiamo -
dobbiamo rispondere a una mail,
ci arriva una cosa che dice:
"Tra un mese ci sarebbe
questo appuntamento -"
e devi rispondere subito,
Ma tu non sai neanche
cosa mangerai questa sera:
come fai a sapere cosa farai tra un mese?
E invece, va programmato tutto;
e ti si chiede continuamente
di rispondere, di correre,
di dare subito qualche cosa
che dimostri che tu sei performante.
Allora, invece, uno deve avere il coraggio
di tapparsi le orecchie,
e di pensare alle cose importanti.
Perché le cose urgenti
si mangiano le cose importanti;
perché le cose urgenti vengono lì,
bussano alla tua porta,
insistono e sgomitano, si fanno spazio.
Le cose importanti invece,
siccome sono solo tue, e ce le hai dentro,
tu le tieni lì e al limite dici:
"Vabbè, ok, le metto da parte.
Andiamo la prossima settimana
a trovare quella persona;
quel libro lo leggiamo un'altra volta;
quella foto la stampo, e la incornicio,
in un altro momento".
Le rinvii perché pensi:
vabbè, queste sono cose mie.
E invece no, le devi proteggere!
Le cose importanti
sono le cose fondamentali della vita,
quelle che fanno la differenza.
Io da quando ho capito questo,
e l'ho capito durante il tempo
che abbiamo vissuto,
quel tempo in cui siamo stati
bloccati in casa,
a partire da quella primavera
in cui c'era tutti i giorni il sole.
La più bella che abbiamo avuto,
e siamo stati in casa.
Ecco: in quella primavera lì,
abbiamo incominciato a renderci conto
che possono accadere delle cose
improvvise, inattese, inimmaginabili
che quando arrivano spazzano via tutto.
Ci dicono che tutte quelle cose
che avevamo nell'agenda,
che erano urgentissime,
invece possono essere cancellate
in nome di qualcos'altro.
E allora, possiamo
incominciare a immaginare
che esista [la possibilità] di fare
anche cose nuove, inimmaginabili
che siano in grado di dare importanza
a quello che sentiamo dentro.
E allora, se noi facciamo questo,
ricominciamo a mettere i pezzi
della nostra vita in fila,
e a dare senso alla nostra vita,
sapendo che il tempo non è infinito,
che non abbiamo tutto il tempo del mondo,
e che dobbiamo tenerci il tempo
per le cose che ci stanno a cuore.
Allora io, tutte le domeniche pomeriggio,
faccio un foglietto -
che porto sempre in tasca -
su cui mi scrivo tre, quattro,
cinque, sei cose importanti.
Non metto mai nessun urgenza,
ma cose importanti che per me hanno senso.
E io so - penso sempre: vabbè,
ma me ne ricorderò tutta la settimana.
Ma io, invece, so
che quando sarà martedì mattina,
o martedì pomeriggio,
io tirerò fuori il foglietto e dirò:
"Ah, ecco che cos'era importante! ".
Perché bombardato dalle urgenze,
me ne sto per dimenticare.
Vi consiglio di fare questo:
rimettete l'importanza
al centro delle vostre vite.
In bocca al lupo!
(Applausi)